hey guys what's up this is andrew from
census.com so in this video as usual
guys we're gonna go through amc gme
press action uh we're also gonna discuss
what is happening in the global market
we have some very very interesting uh
thing happening as well on the oil
market which means that we're gonna have
some uh consequences on all the energy
stocks so it's a very interesting
information that i'm gonna give you guys
here we're also gonna discuss quickly
what is happening on utter because utter
is very hot so let's get into it oh
right guys so i'm gonna start today with
gme all right so let me sum up quickly
the situation what is happening here
guys uh so we are looking for a squeeze
right we are looking for a massive
massive move up
that could go to absolutely crazy levels
so we know that we are targeting
something that can generate really
really a lot a lot of money so uh we are
ready to accept that the priority it
happens is maybe not that high and that
maybe the trades we're gonna do are
gonna be uh trades that don't make money
i'm personally totally fine with that
and uh like i said guys i'm trying to
make money on the rest of the market to
use this money to uh play amc ng squeeze
and if those squeezes happen then i'm
going to be very very happy so
here the situation is that
we are in a situation where the squeeze
is closed so the reason why it is closed
is because we have this massive triangle
that is a squeeze triangle that uh
started as you can see with the highest
point that is a squeeze level uh then we
had some small kind of squeezes you know
the bulls were trying to squeeze again
but bears were very well organized and
it didn't happen but we have something
new that happened last month guys we
have this volume as you can see
absolutely massive volume the biggest
volume we had since the squeeze and you
know the i would say
pull back and uh attempt of new squeeze
in feb 21 so basically something that
happened more than a year ago
um
and this is telling me that um we are in
a situation where it can happen again
very soon uh usually in this kind of
moves we can find uh five waves one two
three four fives so
um to me it's looking very much like a
first wave and right now like a second
wave so um
just like i said on emc before sometimes
second wave are actually not holding at
the support and uh they become you know
deeper
than expected and sometimes then it's
much much harder for bulls to create the
third wave but
when we look at gme we are in a
situation where uh bulls are very strong
all right we're still above the fifty
percent so basically it's like for rsi
everything above the fifty percent fib
ratio is bullish everything below is
bearish you can do the same with the 20
day moving average whenever the price
action on the daily time frame is above
this 20-day moving average we are
bullish and whenever we are below we are
bearish here we have we are above the 50
we are above the 20-day moving average
that is at 149 and we have an rsi at 55
all right so uh i mean you you can see
when you look at those uh momentum
indicators
once again it's a it's a momentum
indicator because it's about the dynamic
of the price action uh when we compare
where is the price action compared to
the recent highs and or and recent lows
which i do with fibs we are talking
about momentum we are talking about
dynamics so here the momentum indicators
are all telling us same for the 20-day
moving average of course for moving
averages moving average crossovers all
of these indicators are momentum
indicators and here uh momentum
indicators are very good and they are
telling us that the move that started
here is still intact so it means that
boos and control on the daily time frame
which we need for a squeeze to happen so
the situation is nice to me now if we
zoom in a little bit guys something very
interesting happened today uh bam bam
bam so i told you in my yesterday's
video that 141.8
was clearly a support level because we
have this uh many reactions that happen
here
i also told you that um
independently of the time frame we are
looking for
consolidation i mean a move a
consolidation on the volume then a
breakout okay this is the usual um
way the press action develops and here
we're gonna do the same thing we have a
move here
here we have a consolidation and we're
looking for a breakout and we had the
breakout but it didn't hold but let's
see maybe both will uh find we will
manage to take back control here on the
hourly timeframe uh i'm going to show
you exactly what what i'm talking about
so here
we have this support clearly identified
at 141.8
and we have this resistance that was
identified yesterday guys which is the
fib uh ratio and which is also a natural
resistance when it's a natural it means
that there are reactions there them
sorry the 38.2
okay i'm trying to as perfectly as i can
okay
so it's the 153
is the fib ratio let me get rid of that
and now
whenever you have roughly the area of um
resistance then you go on a shorter time
frame and you check exactly where
directions and here you can see 140
150
152.3 is the level that we needed to go
through to
have a short-term uh breakout which is a
short-term
um bullish signal uh and we had it as
you can see guys here i put it in green
we have this candle this beautiful
candle with which is a strong breakout
candle that went through this level what
is the problem here and those who
followed my calls guys know what is the
problem here
pam pam pam
look the volume didn't increase then you
can see that we had an increase in
volume on the red bar just right after
so when you see that you need to ask
yourself what happened here so let's
zoom in let's go to 20 minutes time
frame bam bam and as you can see
actually this is not a red bar it is a
green bar all right
it's very clear here
it's a green bar that went through
this level so basically what happened
here guys because usually why do we want
to have volume let me quickly re-explain
we want to have volume because it means
that there were a lot of orders at this
level which means which means that this
was indeed a resistance where bears were
located so if we go through resistance
with that volume it means that it was
not a resistance and it means that the
breakout signal the bullish signal you
have is not reliable here uh we we went
through without volume and we had some
volume right after why why do you think
we had the volume here
at 155 is 155 a resistance level
no
so why do we have a volume here i'm
gonna tell you why it's because whenever
we have a breakout with that volume um
this usually means that the breakout
will not hold so bears
start to sell the breakout because they
know that some bulls are going to buy
here and this they start to sell the
breakout because they believe the
breakout will not hold this is a
strategy called stop hunting and once
again i'm discussing that in uh my
course guys so for those who are
interested in the course just click in
the link in description of this video i
allowed now the monthly payment and i
added for you guys
uh the platinum membership a free
platinum membership of six months yes if
you want to learn how to become a trader
if you want to learn all these
techniques it's going to take time to be
honest for you to really master
everything but that's why i'm here come
in the discord you have a free
membership and you can pay in multiple
payments in four payments guys so i
think the price is very affordable
compared to what you can make with it
and for now i make uh
um you can it's satisfied or 100
refunded for now no one has asked a
refund so all of the members who took
this course and i'm grateful for that
guys none of them asked a refund which
means the course is good quality and you
can you can see by yourself and once
again you have one month to be fully
refunded if you don't like it so don't
wait anymore grab your course and join
the discord guys so here uh what i
wanted to show you guys is that we had
this breakout and then we are coming
back here
so
142.3 is the level so bam so it's not
that good and i mean whenever we have a
breakout with that volume which is here
the case the breakout is fragile so i
personally bought some calls here uh
because i think that um even if it's a
fragile breakout the situation of daily
time frame looks very good and i want to
be positioned in case we have a strong
move up if we don't have it i'm going to
lose my premium i'm fine with that
because once again i made money on the
rest of the market so um
so here once again to me we're in a very
interesting situation i'm not saying
tomorrow we're gonna take 20
but i'm saying that we it's this kind of
uh scenarios this kind of environment
where we usually see some strong moves
up happening why let me explain again
because we're in a second wave
correction uh the second wave looks
strong the momentum is with us uh and
we're having on the very short term some
signs of breakouts some signs of
reversal of short-term reversals so for
now they are not strong but whenever
they're going to be strong the price
action is going to be much higher so
that's why i personally took this
opportunity to buy some calls um i'm
going to post that in the discord very
soon i actually posted it but in the
wrong channel but whatever and here
uh i think that if we are able to close
above 152.3
maybe it doesn't look important for you
guys but i can tell you that for
short-term traders it's very important
that we manage to close above that level
for what they're gonna do tomorrow if
today they're gonna see we close below
tomorrow they're not gonna buy if they
see we close above tomorrow at the open
they're gonna be a lot of buyers that
are following the same techniques as i
do so let's see if we're able to have
this close at this level or not and if
we do guys i remind you what is the big
picture here we are looking for a
squeeze and the squeeze would enter it
its third wave that can be absolutely
massive it can be the biggest move that
we've never seen on gme let's see
and it can go to 500 something like that
so once again what is the probability it
happens guys i don't know but it's not a
90 probability like i said at the
beginning if you're looking for big
profits you need to be uh to accept the
fact that the probability it happens is
low that's why do not over invest and
only invest what you can lose this is
what i'm personally doing and i'm
totally fine if i lose money here and by
the way i lost money on amc jimmy i
didn't lose money i made actually some
money here i lost a lot of money on amc
but i'm still very positive thanks to
the rest of the trades i'm making so uh
bam bam bam
here so yeah the scenario is that maybe
the third wave is gonna start tomorrow i
don't know we're gonna find out amc amc
guys so losing 2.8 when the rest of the
market is losing 1.5 percent uh sorry
this is triple q i'm going to show
triple q as well guys because it's very
important this is all related and we are
right now for me in a situation where
maybe tomorrow is going to be a very
good day i'm gonna explain why so amc
what are we looking for we are looking
for um once again same thing guys we are
in a massive move down much deeper than
i expected uh bulls lost control here
they need to take back control so before
taking back control as usual you have a
move down then you need to consolidate
okay so here as you can see we're moving
down and now for the fourth consecutive
day we are in the same range the 18
range roughly right we are oscillating
between 17 and 19. so this is what we
call a consolidation does it mean we're
going to move higher no it just means
that we are in a scenario where boos are
going to start to see if they can take
back control and for that to happen we
need a catalyst or we need um you know
something some events so here i don't
know what it can be we can zoom in
quickly i mean i'm talking here about
the press action of course the catalyst
can be something else but on the price
action it can be enough so i i mean we
need to go above 19 to need for both to
really start to attack uh for now we
have support at 17.8 if we go below 17.8
today before the close i'm making the
video two
two hours 15 minutes before the close
because guys i'm in france it's just
easier for me i hope it's good for you
as well
um and if we break out on the hourly
time frame below this level guys it
won't be looking good and we would
probably go to the 16 area
i hope we won't and i'm seeing also some
positive
uh
signals here guys look at that it's very
important i'm explaining that as well
guys in my course i know it might seem
complicated but trust me guys if you
know how to use that it's very good i
told you about momentum and jimmy moving
averages
press action uh crossing some
resistances
or some moving averages and um rsi and
macd and here guys look what we have
those who follow the course know even
those who just follow my videos guys
because i'm talking about that quite
often because it's very important to
keep this in mind to look at that guys
what do you see here momentum going
higher
price action going lower all right
here the market made a new low the
momentum made a new high so this is
exactly what is happening this is
basically the um
the momentum is representing the
acceleration so before making uh a
reversal first so basically it means we
go down so the momentum is kind of the
speed more than the acceleration and the
speed need to change sinus so the
acceleration need to um
whatever forget about this acceleration
and speed
thing but what is important is to have
this momentum going higher when the
price action is still going lower before
everything can go up together but
usually it's not going to happen
together you often have uh some
divergence between the price action and
the momentum which is preceding actually
some price action reversals and the
reversal is going to be confirmed
whenever we have a breakout uh in the
price action so here i don't see clearly
any
here okay we can have one look okay
here you can see you need to find to
look for consolidation whenever you have
this momentum information without
average then you need to have a bullish
signal so it can be a candlestick it can
be a breakout it can be um you can kind
of stick pattern i mean
it can be what else it can be a
crossover with a moving average it can
be pretty much whatever you want but it
must be a price action uh bullish signal
and here you can see we are considering
one two three four five reactions uh
under hourly time frame so my take is
that if we are able to close even around
18.7 on the hourly timeframe
with some volume here this would be a
good signal that is going to validate
the signal given by the
bullish divergence so let's see if we're
able to do that uh gme is still below
152.3 i wish we could close above that
so we're going to follow that of course
today guys um
something else i wanted to show you but
very quickly guys i want to show you
something even cooler guys that
everything i'll show you here uh i think
i told you about that already so let me
just
show you that guys you're gonna love it
uh bam bam bam so it's here
as you guys know i am starting uh my
new
uh bambam bam where is it and it's not
here it's here okay attack
okay here we go i'm starting my nfts
guys we are going to launch our nfts in
around one month the website is going
ready we are already starting the
promotion i can tell you we have a very
very high engagement all of my friends
want to buy it all my family of course
want to buy it my previous bosses who
have money they all want to buy they all
believe a lot in the project so here i
just wanted to share with you the last
designs that we're having because they
are just insane they are so cool i i
personally love them but i mean it's my
product so it's pretty normal so as you
can see guys uh we are a top quality nft
project uh because the designer guys is
my cousin it's his job and he's doing
something really really amazing and on
top of that guys look at that this is
the king buu he's really really cool and
on top of that guys we have a very solid
project compared to the other nft
project that i went through guys and
it's seriously not uh i mean i i don't
really trust what they do with the money
i can tell you guys that what we're
gonna do with the money is gonna be
amazing we're gonna use it for um
for to do some crypto arbitrage this is
what we're called the crypto balls and
we're gonna use the uh profits to uh for
the community to buy gifts like watches
cars we want to buy a tesla
so of course it's going to depend on how
uh how far we can go in this project but
if we are able to go far guys it's going
to be a killing we're also going to make
some artistic projects we're going to
make a comic that is telling the story
of crypto bulls that come from satoshi
satoshi is also the creator of the
bitcoin i'm sure you guys know about
that so we're gonna tell the story of
satoshi uh and it's gonna be the story
of what is creep what are crypto what
are nfts uh in a very funny way with a
lot of lighting is going to be a new
generation comic uh that my once again
cousin is working on and we're going to
use some very very advanced techniques
to make it absolutely epic so guys our
project is very very solid our designs
are amazing so just join the project
guys uh the links are in the description
of this video as well the discord is
here guys we're waiting for you uh we
have uh many many members joining every
day we're gonna start to organize some
games some funny things in the discord
of crypto bulls um and it's gonna be
amazing so i want all of you guys to be
there and by the way those who come from
uh trading census channel are gonna be
early bulls and early boos are gonna get
uh basically 30 of the price of the rest
of the members so if you guys join
you're gonna have a price that uh i mean
for sure it's gonna be uh lower than
whatever
uh price uh that there's gonna be later
uh so i'm gonna tell you more about that
project guys but let's come back to the
market here uh i wanted to tell you that
we're in a situation where maybe
something can happen because as i showed
you guys uh amc bullish divergence not
breakout yet but consolidation and maybe
it's gonna be time to go higher and test
the resistances uh gme is making a
breakout on the hourly timeframe is
really developing in a nice second wave
that is uh we're having all the bullish
uh bullish information coming from the
momentum indicators and we are having
here a breakout that is a bit fading but
it is still to me not invalidated as you
can see we went below this 152 level
right now live but we are coming back
right
right to it so let's see if we're able
to close above 152.3 it's important we
do
and
um last but not least guys we are in a
situation where the rest of the market
is bullish by the way we have a negative
beta today between gme and the rest of
the market negative beta means negative
correlation and it's good to see that
because each time gme moved by 100 200
we had this negative beta at play just
before uh sometimes we have the negative
but that play and there is no squeeze
but each time there is a squeeze there
is the negative beta so whenever i see
the negative beta i'm excited because i
feel maybe maybe this time is going to
be the good one so let's see
but we need to have this negative beta
in a bull market all right so we need to
build a bull market and just when the
market drops correct a little bit then
gme goes higher and then when the rest
of the market is rallying it's at that
time that squeezes happen and look here
like i said we need to be in the bullish
environment so are we in the bullish
environment not really right
we are in a correction but there is one
very bullish case which is that this is
actually a first wave this is the second
wave and we have three four five coming
it's personally not my preferred
scenario but it is one scenario and in
this scenario guys we are here at the
support level 338 i told you guys i
bought some shares of triple q yesterday
i'm having a stop loss just here for
those who want to know exactly what we
do come to discord guys and uh you're
gonna see all of our trades i'm trading
with gabrielle as well that is helping
me we are two experienced traders it was
our job guys we know what we do so if
you want to learn once again join the
discord and grab your course you can
join the discord without the course or
you can get the course and have this
code for free so it just means that
you're going to stay longer but at least
you're going to have a course that is
going to be useful all your life
and here i'm using the techniques of the
course of course
and here so i bought here stop lost 335
and uh
we actually you know in a fight no no
one knows really what's going to happen
as long as we're above 338 we are
bullish uh and we might very well be
only in a second wave so um and we are
close to support so maybe tomorrow if
you have here a buddhist reaction and if
you're able tomorrow is gonna be hard
guys let's be honest to take back really
this level because it's like three four
percent but if we're able to in a few
moves
take back the 350 level and start this
third wave guys and funny right because
actually
this one two three four five is very
similar to uh my scenario on jme and amc
so and it needs to go together so i hope
that this is the right scenario of
course i don't know guys um that's why i
use stop losses because uh you know most
of my trades are actually not making
money but those who make money and i'm
going to show you how i manage
a winning position are actually making
much more money than everything else
that is losing and this is how you make
money in trading is by managing your
risk uh bam bam bam and here
sorry i'm just getting rid of those dots
okay
and um what i want you to say yes i want
you to show you so here we are in a
situation where potentially we can start
moving higher we would need to close
above 350 for both to really take back
control and maybe start this third wave
then the real level to take is 370 but
it's quite far we can squeeze
by that time maybe uh and pam pam pam
yeah i want you to show you guys uh two
more things at her so utter is very
bullish guys this is once again an alert
i posted using the techniques guys that
are in the course here breakout with
volume after nice consolidation um so
then we bought around this level and
then the price action is just moving
higher so of course uh sometimes
in those strong moves up the price
action just drops and fades all right so
that's why it's good to take half of the
profits on the way up just below a
resistance so this is what we did here
at 550
and then
uh you need to increase your stop loss
guys so this is exactly what i'm doing
in my discord this is the techniques i'm
trying to teach and here
you have different um actually ways to
place your stop loss your stop loss
always needs to be below a consolidation
but it's only one condition it needs to
be below moving averages and below the
trend line so you check all of that you
check the trend line you take the moving
averages and you take the consolidation
and when i do that i put my stop loss
today at 4 40 and this is exactly guys
what i sent this morning in my discord
uh because i know that a lot of my guys
i are in this trade and uh now it's
topless 440 and then you increase the
target you only have 50 of the position
left but you put 50 of the 50 which is
25 at the next resistance where is the
next resistance you zoom out and you
check a trend line so here we have a
trend line we have a moving averages uh
200-day moving average so the resistance
is one here but it's too close to the
level we took already a bit of the
profit and the next one is this trend
line guys so it's around 7 30. so this
is uh the advice i gave in my discord
this morning and tomorrow we're going to
keep moving the stop loss on the way up
and we're going to adjust the targets if
they need to be for now arter is bullish
and otto can even go higher than that so
let's find out and last thing guys very
interesting i told you yesterday about
the oil market and i told you once again
guys look quickly at the big picture the
big picture is that we are extremely
bullish because we broke out above a
10-year resistance right this trend line
and you know it's a breakout because we
had an increase in volume and a nice
consolidation just just before
actually the consideration was not so
nice but the volume was here um even the
volume was not that nice but it's a
weekly time frame so that's why you
don't really see the volume on weekly
time frames but whatever then when you
come to the um
daily timeframe once again we had this
massive run-up that told us that
something is changing and that right now
uh the communities market is going to be
bullish for the coming year two years
guys it's a weekly signal so it's very
good to use for the long term
so you can position yourself on
everything that looks cheap and related
to energy guys this is what i did and i
made a lot of money doing that and i'm
still gonna make money i'm very sure of
that because i'm positioned very well on
this market on uso i bought some uso
here and on a lot of energy stocks
yesterday i bought some energy stock
that broke out for now i'm not making
money but i'm very sure it's going to
make money soon because here my view is
that as you can see we're breaking out
with that volume so maybe this breakout
is not going to hold but
my view is that it is going to hold
because i think that we are in a very
strong bullish development on the long
term so when i see on the short term
that we have some breakout even if there
is no volume i'm confident this breakout
can hold and here uh so i said that
already yesterday
i took some positions yesterday before
the close and today we have the
confirmation for now of this breakout as
you can see we have this triangle it's
even more visible on the hourly time
frame guys as you can see bam bam bam
here we have one two three four f nah i
don't count this one
five six seven eight ten ten reactions
something like that and bam look then
where is the breakout where is the
breakout pump the breakout is here guys
so the breakout occurs on increase
with an increase in volume so this is
very good then pull back as usual we
found some um
we find some support on a moving average
or the trend line the breakout trend
line whatever here we didn't even touch
the breakout challenge and then we start
to move higher with volume guys with
volume bam so this is confirming that
this is a strong uh bullish move that is
starting so once again i'm not gonna buy
here because i bought before uh but i'm
very happy and i think that this is
going to nice levels i think we are
going guys
to 145 so i don't know maybe in two
months maybe in six months i don't know
exactly how it's gonna develop maybe
like that i think we're gonna be
rejected at 115 but that then we're
gonna break it because uh we tested it
multiple times before we break it we
broke it already once so it's not a very
strong resistance anymore the next
strong resistance is 145 and i can tell
you guys that if the one market is going
there i'm gonna be very happy and i'm
gonna be able to use all the money i'm
gonna make to put it back in gmc ngme if
they have not squeezed yet this is my
plan and that's it for today i hope you
guys enjoyed this video i'm gonna do
another video tomorrow as every day and
if you did enjoy that video guys please
click on this like button and you're
gonna be the first to know to when i
upload anything new and stay close to
show i'll see you guys